this guy knows how to make mega
slingshots he fires cookies at jello
targets every week yokes pravah produces
a new YouTube video is he crazy no he's
just having a lot of fun your name is
Johnny we'd love ivy I've become
addicted to youtube and I can't live
without it cutting the order in real
life yuck sprava is a businessman
working in the electronics industry but
he's always spent his free time building
slingshots
four years ago he posted his first
youtube video every weekend the 48
year-old produces a new video in his
backyard in a small town north of
Nuremberg his niece Yulia presses the
button he financed the expensive
slow-motion camera with proceeds from
his video which are linked to ads
YouTube gives him a portion of the tune
of eight thousand euros generated each
month he hit a [ __ ] doc I never thought
I could make so much money doing this
kind of thing and for most of the time I
didn't for more than three years it
helped pay a little bit for my materials
but now it's turned into a good incoming
calls haha his slingshot channel has
nearly 300,000 subscribers the german
amateur filmmaker shoots his videos in
English hello and welcome to the facial
channel a strong German accent is part
of the Act so if you're in here that's
kind of your control panel here the
dashboard you have to winch which you
can use to [ __ ] the mechanism to pull
the rubber and you have the trigger here
yokes prava says he can speak English
without an accent but fans love is
German pronunciation
what they love most though is when he
gets the target yolks prabhas no gun
freak that's why he often uses food
forgive Sonny Malone there are always a
few people who frown on it and say I
shouldn't waste food I say there's an
abundance of food here I don't think
there's a shortage somewhere because I
shot off a cookie with a slingshot I
think it's better for me to use food as
ammunition instead of consuming it
myself his video channel gets eight
hundred to a thousand comments a day
yokech promises contact to his fans is
important and a source of inspiration
sometimes the even meets his fans face
to face like here at the YouTube video
day in Cologne his slingshot channel is
one of Germany's most successful
channels internationally and there are
good reasons for that success
first of all is they have a very strong
passion and they found anish of content
that the audience likes and they're very
regular and constant and uploading a
second thing is they engage with their
audience meaning that they speak to
their audience they involve them in the
creative process and they continuously
evolve their videos young sprava has
even bigger plans for his channel he
wants to fulfill his lifetime dream of
becoming an actor it was all for and I
want to make a zombie movie a
full-length feature film that I will
release in segments as a series on
YouTube of YouTube fur completion okay
these are my tube is covering part of
the costs and production has already we
got some undead but